the liver is the second largest organ in
the body it consists of four loes
comprised of hundreds of lobules each
lobule the basic structural element of
the liver metabolizes carbohydrates
lipids and
proteins lobules process glucose the
sugar that is the main energy source for
cells glucose from the digestive tract
flows into the lobules where hepatocytes
the primary cell type in the liver store
excess glucose as glycogen and
distribute glucose to the body hepati
sites also secrete bile which helps the
body digest
lipids Coupe first cells reside in the
liver and help to remove toxins and
bacteria from the blood
hepatocytes also produce blood clotting
factors to prevent Hemorrhage other
vital functions performed by the liver
include protein synthesis vitamin
storage and the breakdown of old red
blood
cells because the liver filters toxins
their accumulation can cause liver
failure chronic liver failure the most
common form of liver failure is most
often caused by long-term alcohol
abuse or slow acting Hepatitis B or C
infection chronic liver failure causes
damage through curosis or scarring of
the liver as cells die over time they
are gradually replaced with scar tissue
that forms
nodules the scar tissue blocks the flow
of blood through the liver slowing the
metabolism of nutrients and filtration
of toxins gradually diminishing liver
function acute liver failure is less
common than chronic liver failure common
causes of acute liver failure are
poisoning such as an overdose of
acetominophen or other
medications or acute infection with
hepatitis A or B which rapidly kills
hepatocytes therosis is not
reversible so treatment focuses on
sensation of alcohol consumption
prevention of disease progression and
and treatment of
complications the only definitive
treatment for chronic liver disease is a
liver
transplant there are vaccines to prevent
infection with hepatitis A and B but not
C interferon and other antiviral drugs
such as ribavirin block the replication
of viral
hepatitis
when acute liver failure is caused by an
overdose of acetominophen it is treated
with netal cystine commonly known as
mucom Mist if administered shortly after
an overdose mucom Mist helps the liver
safely excrete acetominophen
metabolites
that